it's just like a zoom conference call
with punching some other kids around the
world you all have this joker mask this
joker taunts Batman with YouTube videos
I definitely want to see the Joker prank
Batman by taking the tires off the
Batmobile rock stars and welcome back to
rogue theory I'm off screen producer
Zach Huddleston again on screen what has
happened and this is the show where we
go rogue on the nerdy topics that
everybody's talking about and with me
today what a panel we have nobody I
would rather be remotely doing a show
with then of course good friend the man
the myth the legend
Eric vas hello thanks for having me back
on screen Zach what do you mean thanks
for having you back you're always here
but you know who's not always here first
time on the show we're super excited to
have writer and comedian Erika wusu with
what a folks and writer and host of the
geek history lesson podcast mister Jason
Inman thanks for having me can I just
say exactly like I'm so excited to have
Jason and Musa on the show I've been big
fans of yours Jason for awhile and the
same to you Eric yeah man it's so
awesome and then a wusu and I have been
like doing sketch comedy together for
for like five years now and I've been
trying to find a way to get him on new
rock stars we're so glad to finally have
you here because we know you're as big a
nerd as the rest of us are so oh yeah
we're blowing this casting news for the
Batman Matt Reeves and Robert Pattinson
Batman movie that's coming out right we
owe Paul Dano is the Riddler Oh Colin
Farrell is as penguin oh cool cool cool
and then we heard this latest rumor that
it's gonna be part of a planned trilogy
and in the second and third movie
they're gonna introduce the Joker a
character we've seen almost as much as
the Batman certainly lately we've seen
so many Joker's right the the Heath
Ledger Joker wasn't that long ago then
we got to your Leto and Joaquin Phoenix
and his oscar-winning performance
there's been a lot of Joker in our life
but
maybe there's room for more what I want
to know from you what I want you to go
rogue on is what's a new tape that we
haven't seen in a Batman film yet what's
a new way we can see the Clown Prince of
Crime that we haven't already okay so
the biggest thing you have with the
Joker is trying to do something
different by the way I also want to
point out can you believe we now live in
a world where there's the oscar-winning
Joker performance twice over now so
anyway but you have to figure out like
what do you do that's different because
I think if you just do murderer Joker
we've seen it over and over again if you
do anything close to mobster Joker
that's just what Jack Nicholson did so I
would take on a little bit of modern day
also at the same time stealing from a
classic Superman villain called the
prankster now if you don't know about
the prankster the prankster would
basically pull off some sort of prank or
shenanigan on Superman or tell him about
a future crime and almost dare him to
stop them and generally when Superman
would try to stop that person he would
get insulted or a pie in the face or all
kind of things like that we live in a
YouTube prank world so I'm saying if
this Joker's going against Robert
Pattinson or baddest and however you
want to call that this Joker taunts
Batman with YouTube videos basically
daring the Batman on YouTube or all of
social media to stop him before he
commits his crime and if the Batman
can't stop this he's gonna get a pie in
the face he's gonna record Batman
screwing up to all of his so Gotham City
loses faith in the Batman you know and
also it ties back to the very first
appearance of Joker ever in Batman issue
number one where Joker came onto the
radio and said I'm gonna kill this man
by midnight stop me Batman so update
that make Joker the ultimate prankster I
really like that Jason especially it
kind of somebody who kind of pranks
Batman also helps point out the
ridiculousness of this rich guy that
drives around totally you know here's a
crazy car and stuff like that right
that's a newer take right rarely do we
get to poke fun at like Batman in his
own world it could be a lot of
one-percenter jokes in there who knows
yeah that's great
Jason I really like that and and maybe
that also is nice too and that we could
see that'd be like a recurring thread
right even if Joker is not the main
antagonist in the second or third movie
right if Batman is also fighting penguin
or Riddler or whoever rightly you can
see that adding to the stew of Batman or
whatever there's nothing to say that if
you do it on this take that we couldn't
in the first the Batman movie scroll the
camera past the television and then boom
we get a quick snippet of whoever the
Joker's gonna become performing a prank
kind of like what we saw Hank McCoy in
the first x-men movie yeah
all right like some kids looking at his
smartphone yeah bus stop or something
and you just happen to see a little
flash of it before he's like stop look
at my phone stranger yeah an Alf it's
like oh dear what's happened to golf him
they're watching prank videos but you
know what Jesus I was fully ready to
give you to Sparkle bucks for that
theory but the double Alfred imitation
Oh bumps you up to three you get a three
points for that you know and this is
very tight in because those three
Sparkle points transfer into three
multicolored Batman pops normal horny
green lovely Erica woo sue how do you
think we could put a new spin on the
Joker well first I want to say that was
a great take Jason I definitely see the
Joker pranked Batman by taking the tires
off the Batmobile I can't even drive out
of the cave to stop mischief that's
fantastic I think the new Joker should
be kind of inspired by Cesar Romero who
played the sixties Batman opposite Adam
West so just very theatrical and
maniacal and just super like just just
like a Shakespearean villain almost
tormenting the Batman
like that would be a good foil to Batman
stoic I'm gonna get you rare crime
nature and I think that would be good
opposite Robert Pattinson banks I'm
sorry and new Batman movies and so that
also in this lake that would make it
timeless right because you know no
matter what shenanigans but the Joker
takes part in whether it's you know
pranks and YouTube stuff or you know
back in the 60s getting a Giant Bomb and
getting Batman to run around with it on
a pier like no matter where where the
Joker is in time like he has to be a
theatrical foil and just do the most
essentially and be the biggest most
ridiculous villainy can be so I think
inspired by Cesar Romero that would be a
great Batman villain to have in these
new Robert Pattinson Batman movies I
love that Eric it also like the way you
just described him also makes me think a
little bit about Mark Hamill's animated
Joker to Wright who was like very kind
of over the top you know but he didn't
have a mustache but almost like mustache
twirling or whatever to the other plus
is that if you're going for like Cesar
Romero whoever's the actor has to
legitimately grow a giant moustache and
you must paint over it with the white
paint and so then it becomes the it
becomes the reveal to the audience where
they're like oh the guy with the
moustache he can't be the Joker
yeah the Warner Brothers editors are
going to be so happy that they don't
have to CGI out another ya know in this
movie you're going to want to that was
great
Eric and for that I also award you three
Sparkle buck points so I put those in
what do those turn into those turn into
a joke or playing card
like it though Oh appropriate yeah well
I mean I don't know how many I don't
know how many decks of cards you have
but we need a cowboy okay you know rock
stars didn't covered in the budget for
today so I
I usually throw my Joker's away so that
shows what where I'm putting my
priorities play four spades you gotta
have the Joker's available for the whole
point
Eric Voss what's your hot new take on
our old friend the Joker okay well I I
do agree with what I feel like all of us
are saying that we could use a break at
least for a couple years from the Joker
Joaquin Phoenix's take was fantastic and
in my mind he pledges take is as fresh
and recent has ever so like yeah if you
want to really delay this joker reveal
to like the third of these movies I'm
totally fine with that like I I like
that we're getting penguin and the
Riddler in the Batman and I would love
for the second one maybe to explore
either Hugo Strange or court of owls no
I think there's a lot of fresh ground
with characters that we have not seen in
live-action on the big screen before so
yeah maybe we can come back in 2026 too
to Joker and the third one and yeah I
agree with you guys it needs to be
something we haven't seen before and I
like this idea of a social media angle
Jason and I think there's a way to do it
even more even more timeless like Oh
Lucy was saying I wonder if there's like
a way we can go back to the essence of
what social media is it's like virality
right like it's it's word of mouth it's
just like people connecting with each
other and I wonder if there's the way
you can do that pre-internet and kind of
turn
Joker into this mythologized fearsome
figure like Slenderman or the Candyman
or whatever the boogeyman is a Bloody
Mary or something like that this this
legend this urban legend that kids pass
along to each other and try to replicate
the way that like now on social media
kids are unfortunately like reenacting
these Slenderman things that they like
the Slenderman hypnotizes you to go out
in the woods I'm like see if you can
kill your friend or something horrible
you know what if Joker is that figure
that like we don't even if Joker lives
anymore he's just kind of like legendary
figure this ghost story that kids pass
along to each other and Batman has to
try to like stop this from spreading
so the Joker is kind of immortal in that
way and that he's like tricking these
kids through different means and Batman
his mission is to try to like go back to
the patient zero
who started this urban legend and he's
going he thinks it is a joke of the
Joker's still alive somewhere out there
who's just perpetuating this myth and
eventually he goes to somewhere like you
know Bangladesh or something and he
finds some kid like some thirteen year
old kid at his computer who just like
turns around and he just like smiles at
Batman and it just puts on a joker mask
and then you see his computer it's just
like a zoom conference call with
hundreds of other kids around the world
who all have this Joker mask and just
laughs and that's how the movie ends
like Batman realizes you can't stop it
you know whoa darkus Batman ending ever
I love I love that man because that is
very similar to like what happens to the
Joker and Batman Beyond where it becomes
like a yeah The Joker's with the Z yeah
it's also similar to there's like an
early 90s graphic novel digital justice
that where Joker becomes like a virus
like there's a Joker virus that early
days of when people that computers or
just magic it's like the net it's like
wait they can increase
oh yeah I love that Eric I I also love
like we've even seen this like a very
kind of grounded crime version of this
with like Keyser söze and the usual
suspects right we're like a kind of a
real character maybe goes beyond I mean
you're spending something different
where it's not necessarily a real
character it is more the ideas more
powerful but like yeah I love that and I
love Bangladesh not nearly enough movies
resolved in Bangladesh are those to you
I really enjoyed that I enjoyed the 90s
morality of it and for that Erik Bosse
you get three Sparkle bucks
boy three well they come out as sparkle
bucks on my end looking when when Eric
hosts the show that goes the opposite
way he back to me I mean that's coy
Philip took all my toys he said that I'm
too old for them that's not fair Jason
disagrees Jason yes I do I have so many
toy
in this room you have no idea never grow
up well regardless I think that the four
of us need to agree to meet back up here
in like 2022 when this movie is actually
being made and then really discuss like
what's gonna happen with Joker okay
wonderful before we move on to talk
about one of our favorite guardians of
the galaxy a quick shout out some of the
people that helped bring this show and
all of our shows to you here at new rock
stars
two out of three guys will experience
some hair loss in their life some male
pattern baldness and that's a bummer I
don't think anybody really wants that or
enjoys that so keeps let's it be easier
and more affordable than ever to get
treatment for that hair loss and to help
you keep the hair that you have keeps
offers generic versions of the only two
fda-approved hair loss products out
there but at half the cost of your local
pharmacy hey and you don't even have to
go to the doctor's office that's one of
the best parts about keeps you can do it
all from home you meet with a doctor
online they ship you the treatment it
comes to your house you have to wait in
line you don't got to put on a mask and
drive your car and do all this stuff it
all at home and that's great so find out
why keeps has more five-star reviews
than any of its competitors and nearly a
hundred thousand men trust keeps for
their hair loss prevention medication so
if you if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to keeps calm
slash rogue theory to receive your first
month of treatment free that's K e EP s
calm a slash rogue theory to start today
ah sometimes our online research at new
rock stars for our videos takes us into
some questionable places like for
instance recently Eric had to help
answer what happens to pregnant women
during the snap yeah have gone down some
very weird rabbit holes and my YouTube
recommendations are real fun and so it's
times like that where it doesn't matter
what mode you're using you know
incognito or whatever or how many times
you clear your browsing history your
internet service provider can still see
every site you visited okay and that's
why whether at home or work we use
Express VPN
expressvpn is an app that reroutes your
internet connection through their secure
servers so your ISP can't see the sites
you visit expressvpn keeps all of your
information secure by encrypting 100% of
your data with the most powerful
encryption available
it runs seamlessly in the background you
just tap one button and boom you're
protected expressvpn is available on all
your devices phones computers even your
smart TV if you use that so there's no
excuse for you not to be using it
protect your online activity today with
the VPN rated number 1 by C net and
wired visit our exclusive link
expressvpn comm slash rogue and you can
get an extra three months free on a
one-year package that's exp our e SS VPN
comm / rogue ro ug UE if you haven't
already seen that in the title of this
video express.com slash rogue to learn
more every week we play a game of rogue
theory with our patrons our patreon
patrons on our new rockstars discord
server where we pick a couple people to
pitch their own theories on a fun topic
and then everybody votes and picks a
winner this week we asked three patrons
to pitch their theories for where they
think daredevil is going to show up next
in the MCU we had some great ones
Avenger nerd and Bru kheh
Brook had some great theories but the
winner this week was quiz no I love your
sandwiches and I also love your theory
and he pitched the daredevil is actually
gonna show up in the Falcon and Winter
Soldier Disney Plus series he's gonna be
in there helping Sam and Bucky fight off
Zemo and bullseye is gonna debut and
that both of those henchmen it's gonna
be revealed at the end we're working for
dr. doom which good God if if we get a
dr. doom reveal in a Disney Plus show
that's really gonna blow up the MCU I
feel like could set up a new Big Bad you
like that theory right your advice yeah
I was a big fan of that one I especially
liked how the primary setting of it was
the new Baxter building you were going
along with that theory that seems pretty
likely that the Avengers tower in the
MCU its new ownership is the
Reed Richards the Fantastic Four and I
just like visualized this idea of like
kind of like the raid you know just kind
of working up the floor for that
building finding up the bad guys and
then trying to take it back and I love
anything that you can get Charlie Cox
daredevil to actually admit the fact
that there is this tower in the skyline
of his setting because those Netflix
shows never just pan up a little bit
just to show us that building in the
spot of the MetLife building in
Manhattan so I love this theory and I
love the possibility in dr. doom because
that guy definitely needs a reboot and
and all new rock stars fans know if
there's one thing Erik Voss loves more
than like MCU movies it's real estate
that guy is a is a stand for buildings
okay so you two can play along with
future discord robe theories if you
become a patron of new rock stars and
log on to our discord server we play
every week it's a great time speaking of
playing we got to move on to our next
topic one of our favorite guardians of
the galaxy characters and and I think
like a character in the MCU that's had
this really interesting arc is nebula
right we get introduced to her as this
kind of antagonistic Gamora and fan OSes
nastier daughter right and then you know
she kind of has this great arc of
redemption and by guardians of the
galaxy - she's helping them out and in
event adventures endgame she's both a
good guy and a bad guy depending on
which timeline she's coming from
so that leaves so many opportunities for
places that nebula can go in the future
of the MCU so pitch me on where is
nebulae gonna show up next what's she
gonna be doing what's her agenda Erik
Voss what do you think okay to me when I
think of the character of nebula an MCU
the moment that stands out to me is that
monologues that rant she goes on in
volume 2 which is talking to Krag lit
about Thanos about how he made her spar
with her sister Gamora and every time
she lost he cut off a piece of her until
like piece by piece she was tortured and
then we get like an echo of that
infinity war where they had that great
that pans around her and she has like
all of her parts are separated just like
remind her of that tortuous upbringing
so what I want to see is a story in
which nebula gets to go back down
history and and down memory lane to look
at each of these parts and hold the
manufacturers of those parts responsible
so like it seems like volume 3 is gonna
explore Rockets backstory and he like
her has a bunch of cybernetic implants
he has a similar upbringing so I think
they're both gonna like set out together
and maybe go visit half worlds or
whatever that origin was we're like
those cybernetic surgeons are putting in
these parts to them and causing them all
this pain but then rocket might go off
on his own side story to maybe go back
in his history with with Lyla is old
flame whereas I think Gamora it's gonna
go off on her own trajectory and track
down each of the people baby please some
of the serial numbers on the parts and
be like oh so you made this wrist
implant and then like use it to like
choke them or something like that
it's gonna be like her Kill Bill story
as she goes from planet to planet to
like avenge each of the the people who
caused her the pain because she can't
kill thanos anymore so she's got a it's
gonna hold someone responsible and that
to me that that's nebula that's that's
her whole modus operandi I love that
Erik that's such like a fun and you
could see that matically like the
parallel of them both dealing with both
they're like histories and how that
manifests in their bodies right right
yeah uh I also I mean you could probably
cuz nebula is mostly a good guy now that
like as she's like yeah killing the dude
that made her wrist but he's also like a
human trafficker or something like that
right like these are good honest trades
people that she's wiping out and if you
had any kind of connection your uh what
was the three book billboards term like
you're culpable right so like you might
not have done it yourself but there's
blood on your hands yeah if you yeah if
you agree to be a fan Oh subcontractor
you've got you've got some red in your
ledger yeah that's great
Eric I love that
in honor of her sister Gamora I award
you to green Sparkle but cards Wow to
green Sparkle books thank you sir
for whatever reason came out like a
whole bunch of them so that is like the
printers broken that's the North
Hollywood exchange rate I don't know
yeah we got a real bad inflation up here
ah wonderful
Erica wusu where do you think we might
see nebula next yeah I think nebula is
on chart to find her sister Gamora in
the what not the next time we see them I
think she teams up with Rocket Raccoon
and Peter quill to find Gamora and they
do and I think the conflict becomes
Gamora
and Peter quill kind of pulling and
vying for gamora's attention because now
nebula is a good guy she wants to be
like partners in crime with her sister
wants to get closer to her right now
that kind of as the slate has been wiped
clean because we have this new Gamora
from 2013 or whatever and quill misses
her he was in anguish he was so sad over
her death that he ruined their chance
and stopped the snap so he's extra like
longing for Gamora so they kind of Peter
quill and nebula kind of go back and
forth it's almost like a weird love
triangle but like not everyone's trying
to bang oh yeah meanwhile Rocket Raccoon
is like I like what boss is saying about
him trying to find his origin parts and
people who play them together I really
like that Eric because I think that
points out like what I think will be a
really interesting thing in the next
guardians of the galaxy movie the fact
that like these characters have kind of
like worked through a lot of stuff right
like Gamora and nebula sisters have kind
of like built their relationship and
obviously Peter and Gamora have built a
relationship but like that kind of gets
erased if it's like weird Gamora from
the past which is great for like movie
plots right because we don't want people
to like have worked through all their
stuff right we want them to have to go
through that stuff so like it is like a
great way to like reset the conflict on
all those characters and like a new fun
way cuz now Peter
nebulae have a relationship that they
have built even though they won't have
the same relationship with Gomorrah yeah
and I think that's a real fun like oh
sorry
who's our sketch team and I think like
that reversal is really fun because it's
on volume - it was like nebula trying or
Gamora trying to teach nebula about the
value of like having a family that you
can choose and that all about the
connection with your team and now that
would be flipped right so like nebula
has to like reteach this less than to
her sister that she previously taught
her in another life at school yeah sure
that's great Erik I enjoyed that and I
award that theory to green sparkle
points thank you so much I'm really
gonna enjoy these that translate into an
American flag and a Puerto Rico fridge
sticker this is nice nice wonderful
Jason what do you think the next stage
of nebula is gonna be so I'm going a
little bonkers without not quite
positive my I'm going I'm going way out
there I think in Avengers in game where
present-day nebula the good nebula the
one that had been palling around with
the avengers nebula killed the past bad
nebula that was the end symbolic end of
all her bad acts so nebula going forward
is completely good so the thing that I
always loved about the guardians of the
galaxy franchise and it's something that
they've kind of gotten away from and
it's something I would like them to see
to go back to is in the first movie they
are all criminals they are all bad
people
so if nebula has spent the last five
years of this in-game timeline pound
around the do-gooders of the Avengers I
kind of think she would be like you know
what I don't think these a-holes are
good enough to find my sister but there
was an organization out there that was
really good and reminded me a lot of the
Avengers so I'm going to say that nebula
is going to use her tech
to restart the nova corps and that you
will see nebula as a nova agent and then
when the guardians and guardians three
go back to their sort of criminal senses
you know so so the guardians get up to
some mischief and they're like you know
what we need to activate adam warlock
because he's been hinted for two movies
now that nebula and her do her new
do-gooder pals the nova corps will be
like you can't do that that's the
stupidest thing in the galaxy and it'll
become a nebula as sort of the cops and
they're the Smoky's and the guardians
the galaxies are the bandits and they're
gonna is gonna be a chase that's fun
i do like getting back to the like the
original like smugglers you know raiders
of the lost ark kind of energy of that
first movie that's for fun well then
that way it gives you it allows you to
like have nebula kind of be like i can't
remember their john c reilly character
from the first movie so the entire
movies like you guys are like i was i
was just working with war machine and
captain marvel you guys are pathetic
berating she's like yeah st drill
sergeant exactly well cuz peter quill
like he's been dust for five years
whereas nebula has gotten better and
better and better so like peter quill is
a joke to her now i I love to cuz like
the entire Nova Corps got wiped off off
screen yeah hate like you know they had
this like very inglorious death so I do
love like making them to like McHale's
Navy or like F Troop of the MCU and Nova
has to come in or nebula has to come in
and like beat them into shape like it
would also like that would be like a
great if you think about it like a great
like end of your first act twist where
like there is a new Nova Corps and
everybody's like oh man we don't know
who the master Nova is and then they
walk into a room and like Empire Strikes
Back Darth Vader at the dinner table
there's nebula and you could get that
what the f moment with Peter Cole like
you literally could drop the f-bomb and
right there and it could be every
trailer moment it could just be C Peter
quill be like what the guardians of the
galaxy
boom KC and the Sunshine Band yeah I
love that that sounds all three of these
theories sound really really fun and
like you could totally picture them and
even the characters none of you
mentioned you know like oh where does
Drax fit in there or whatever
you totally can picture that how that
ensemble is gonna work I love that Jason
I award you I know this is gonna seem
like totally out of nowhere but to
Sparkle buck point oh thank you and mate
and they just transformed into a pink
and purple Batman wow he is like a
Crayola crayon box I said never grow up
you gotta keep your color Batman that's
wonderful um you know normally this
would be the part in the show where we
we where we recap the scores but I know
because I get hurt on the points that
everybody has the exact same number of
points I mean okay well I guess
everybody has seventeen who knows as we
head into our final segment here the
road questions these are random weird
little questions that often provoke
funny answers maybe the first one this
week Keanu Reeves said that the reason
he came back for a fourth Matrix movie
was that he loved the script and it was
something we can take nourishment from
which is just such a Keanu Reeves phrase
take nourishment from the story
so speaking of nourishment nourishment
am i pronouncing that like a Canadian
person I don't know what what kind of
snack do you think this fourth Matrix
movie will be the equivalent of I'll go
first I think he's talking about red
vines because we all know that red vines
are not as good as Twizzlers and once
you taste them you immediately regret
your decision and you don't want them
and that's what I think the matrix for
is going to be not optimistic
I think the
the snack equivalent will be that
delicious amazing looking filet mignon
that cipher was eating when he was
meeting with Agent Smith I think that to
me when I think of nourishment like Oh
God I could just watch that on loop and
that will just be my my ASMR that I will
never be able to be a vegan because of
that clip great yeah I think the new
matrix is gonna be essentially dippin
dots because it's going to be kind of
futuristic a little bit but then we're
gonna realize we saw this like 20 years
ago
so it's not that new I think it's gonna
be as colorful as Wachowski siblings his
hair it's gonna be great wonderful I
like all three of those answers so I
can't get past
Jason saying red vines I think it's so
appropriate for the movie that gave us
red pill right no yeah happy accident
I'll work you one this is not really red
it's kind of pink okay
next road question ah Kenneth Branagh
Branagh Branagh I can't pronounce it
Branagh
uh direct thank you I'll just go with
that just play this his pronunciation of
it director of the first Thor movie and
star of upcoming Christopher Nolan movie
tenet said that he's not actually sure
if he's the villain of the movie or not
because the script was so confusing
so obviously Christopher Nolan writes
these insane puzzle box scripts but with
his brother Jonathan Nolan and other
people but what do you think about this
script was there something extra
confusing that didn't have anything to
do with the plot maybe there's a strange
font or something like that
what confused Kenneth Branagh so much I
think what confused him is that they
weren't handed printed copies of it he
just brought in two clones of Robert
Pattinson one was speaking in Reverse
and the other was speaking for they were
talking at the same time and brothers
this I'd can't make heads or tails of it
great I think because of the the time
effect the backwards and forwards
through time thing
Kevin whatever his last name is wasn't
sure if he was a hero or villain because
he wasn't sure if he was smiling or
frowning or scowling because of how time
kept going back and forward so just
inverted his face in the script so you
didn't know how to take it when actually
acted the world perfect loved it Jason I
think the reason why Kenneth Branagh is
confused about whether he is a hero or
villain is because I don't believe that
there are characters in this movie I
believe that every human being is movie
is plane remember the inception noise
the bomb I think I'm going full grant
morrison here Chris manola has made a
movie about realized fifth-dimensional
sounds becoming human form that's the
reason why nobody has any idea what this
movies about it's very no word all right
yeah that's definitely Christopher
Nolan's next movie whatever okay
wonderful no points awarded it all rolls
over to the next one our final question
video came out this week or late last
week of you know Disney World has
started to reopen some of its areas and
parks and in one of its kind of retail
areas they have like two stormtroopers
like acting out like a scripted skit
about social distancing and like they're
playing the audio of the stormtroopers
over the PA which is both great and
extremely strange and perfect for the
times we live in so give me your best in
character like the more you know PSA
from a Star Wars character
alright so mine is imagine a person in a
giant foam glob and you'll know as soon
as I do the voice be like oh ho ho you
know social distance you go to carbonite
Oh
I put on chain that's great
wonderful okay back that way dress this
Java yeah that was Han Solo okay yeah
yes yes I'll do kylo Ren from last Jedi
and he's just like holding out his hand
he goes don't take my head
I know you want to but don't you dare
take it like you fight the urge and then
he then he shatters like a hand
sanitizer station or something like that
okay great
love it alright so mine is of Yoda all
two feet of him and his glory it's back
from the dead and he comes up to people
and he's like purifying ourselves you
must love it all three of those were
really good and all three of you really
committed to the characters which I
appreciate I award each of you all of
the sparkle bucks again inflation is
real nothing means anything and you know
it's at this point that I am supposed to
declare a winner oh look at all those so
many Batman's we didn't even get to the
bottom of the Batman no you did we did
if you were gonna make me pulp another
one I was gonna be like it turned into
Bob Ross you're we're all winners here
today and again thank you Jason and Men
follow
we've got his social media handles
underneath us right now check him out on
a history lesson yes deep history lesson
thank you very much and all the other
places that you can catch him Erica wusu
follow him on social media and other
places when when live performance
returns to the earth maybe we'll see you
more live somewhere
ketchup doing really fun stand-up sketch
comedy all manner of performance around
the Los Angeles area and and Eric Voss
what do we got coming up on the channel
this week we have our rewatch our
infinity soccer rewatch of captain
marvel we found some new very
interesting stuff to tie into the whole
infinity saga and we have a fun episode
of big question coming out on Sunday
that's going to do like a defense of the
plot holes and unfair criticisms of
Avengers in game because being the top
grossing film of all time is not enough
I love it I love it and right in your
wheelhouse defending things wonderful
and and you know what because I do have
to declare a winner but I was so happy
to have her I don't want either of our
new first-time guests Eric and and Jason
to feel short-handed so I'm just gonna
make both of them losers and Eric Voss
you win today but you put the table he's
also the only one of the three of you I
have to work with her my name is pink
Batman is very angry Eric do you have a
parting wish is the winner in honor of
the billeted based music trailer that
just dropped this week I want us all to
do our air guitars and air the car out
the episode okay perfect
okay that's it for this episode of rogue
theory don't forget to subscribe to the
rogue theory podcast and follow you
rockstars on twitter and social medias
and of course like this video share it
with friends bye
[Music]